[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده من
حلقات افكار الاستاذ والاستاذ طبعا هو
الاقتصادي الكبير الدكتور جودي عبد الخالق
مساء الخير معال الدكتور مساء الخير ليك
وساده المشاهدين في كل مكان الله يخلي
حضرتك عندي سؤال مباشر حضرتك لماذا تعتقد
ان التعويم وتحرير العمله المحليه ليس حلا
ولا يجب ان يكون محور اهتمامنا في مصر او
في غير مصر النظريه بتاعه التعويم
والتخفيض جزء منها تقوم على قانون او
قاعده او شرط خلي شرط اللي هو شرط مارشال
ليرنر مارشال ليرنر اسمه شرط مارشال ليرنر
مارشال ده كان اقتصادي ا كلاسيكي
عاش في اواخر القرن واوا القرن العش في
جامعه كمبريدج
عظيم ويرنر اقتصادي
امريكي يعني الجيل التالي للجيل بتاع
مارشال وكتابات الاثنين ترجمت في هذه
القاعده القاعده بتقولي ان يشترط لكي يؤدي
التخفيض تخفيض العمله الوطنيه الى تحسين
حاله الميزان التجاري وبالتالي انفراجه
قضيه الناد الاجنبي
يشترط الاتي رقم واحد انا عندي مرونه عرض
السلع المحليه تكون عاليه ما المقصود
بمرونه العرض انه ارتفاع بسيط في سعرها
ممكن يؤدي الى زياده كبيره في الكميه
المعروضه معنى عندك طاقه انتاجيه تسمح لك
ها بزياده الانتاج وبالتالي زياده العرض
مع كل زياده طفيفه في في السعر فعلى سبيل
المثال لو اخدنا من يعني السؤال ده قد
يبدو كوميك كوميدي شويه انما خد حاله
البصل في مصر كويس انت عندك مساحه معروفه
محدده من الارض مخصصه لزراعه الايه البصل
ا مع تغير سعر الصرف اصبح مغري جدا
للمصدرين ان هم بدل ما يبيعوا البصل في
الداخل يبقو في الخارج عظيم طيبظ هيحصل ده
وبالتالي انت بتنقل كميات من البصل من
ساحه الاستهلاك المحلي الى ساحه الاستهلاك
اللي هي الخارجيه النتيجه ايه النتيجه ان
بتاثر على توازن السوق الداخلي فيرتفع سعر
الايه البصل سعر البص واحد اثنين انه ما
عندكش طاقه لزياده الانتاج محليا بحيث انه
ا تقدر تستفيد من الفرص المتاحه للايه
للتسويق وبالتالي مش هتقدر تصدر وتبيع
كميه اكبر من البصل ومن ثم لا تتوقع ان
يحدث زياده ملموسه في الصادرات ككل
وبالتالي ماتتوقعش تحسن في الايه الميزان
التجاري بمعنى صادرات ك تزيد ورداتك تقل
فدي الشرط الاول اللي هو يبقى عندك مرونه
الجهاز الانتاجي على زياده الانتاج من
السلع التي تدخل في التجاره الدوليه مع اي
تحسن طفيف في سعرها نتيجه للايه للتعويم
اثنين انه ايضا يكون في مرونه عاليه نسبيا
للطلب المحلي على السلع المستورده انا
عايز طبعا يعني هو الموضوع يعني انا بحاول
ابسطه ولكن في في حدود انما الفكره
الجوهريه اللي فيه تعويم
بمعنى تعديل سعر العمله الوطنيه مقابل
العمله
الاجنبيه يترتب عليه اثرين
مهمين اذا توفرت شروط مايه الاثر الاول
بنسميه اثر تقليل الانفاق ان لما السعر
بيعلى الانفاق بيقل ففي المجمل الانفاق
الكلي الليل الشرط الثاني هو تحويل
الانفاق بمعنى بدل من الانفاق على سلع
مستورده يتحول الانفاق الى سلع ايه منتجه
محليه في الحاله دي بيبقى مفيد الحاله دي
بيبقى مفيد طيب ازاي نضمن انه ما نسميه
اثر التحويل واثر
التقليل بيتحقق هنا بنرجع لموضوع المرونات
وبالتالي بقول
انه
عندما يكون لدى الاقتصاد او في الاقتصاد
قدره على زياده الصادرات استجابه
ل زياده الطلب في الخارج يبقى في الحاله
ديت تزيد الصادرات وعندما يكون للاقتصاد
قدره على تقليل الانفاق على الواردات
نتيجه لارتفاع سعر الوردات يبقى اذا
الصادرات زادت الوردات
قلت الميزان التجاري سيه سيتحسن في
النهايه دي الفكره الاساسيه في في الموضوع
بن عليه ب بشرط مارشال لين الكلام المقعر
ده اللي انا قلته عشان الاقتصاديين اللي
بيتابعو اه لازم نبقى مجموع المرونه
القيمه المطلقه لمرونه المرونه السعريه
للصادرات والمرونه السعريه للوردات تبقى
اكبر من
واحد الواقع والدراسات المتاحه تؤكد ان
هذا ليس هو الحال في الحاله حاله اقتصاد
زي الاقتصاد المصري وبالتالي في الواقع
الرهان على الرهان
على التعويم ومن ثم تخفيض قيمه العمله
لتحسين الاوضاع الرهان خاسر في تقدير
استاذ حضرك اتاكد ان انا فهمت كلام حضرتك
يعني انا يعني اعيده مره تانيه حضرك صحني
ان انا اخطات التعويم لن تعتقد انه لن
يكون مفيد في حاله مصر وفي حاله دول
مماثله للاقتصاد المصري لسببين بسيطين
السبب الاول انه التعويم هدي الى انخفاض
العمله وانخفاض العمله هدي الى انخفاض
انخفاض قيمه العمله وانخفاض قيمه العمله
هدي الى انه الصادرات هتبقى سعرها جذاب
للعالم الخارجي وده جيد لكن بالنسبه لمصر
مش جيد قوي لان انا ما عنديش جهاز انتاجي
ضخم قادر على التصدير بشكل كبير
والاستفاده من هذه الميزه الامر الثاني
انه انا عشان اصدر اي شيء انا مضطر
للاستيراد سلع وسيطه وبالتالي الصادرات قد
تفقد جاذبيتها لان هي محتاجه حا الى
استيراد الاول مكونات كث صحيح الامر
الثاني انه الناس بتعوم علشان تنعش
الانتاج المحلي وتقلل الواردات اذا اذا
كنت انا بنتج او بستورد سلع اساسيه كثيره
ذكات زراعات او صناعات او غيره وما عنديش
بديل ليها محلي فانا غير فانا عاجز على ان
انا اتوقف عن استيرادها وبالتالي كل اللي
انا ه جنيه هو ارتفاع الاسعار عامه في
الداخل حرك تقصده طيب وهدي مثالين بقى
عشان نوضح الكلام دو لو بتكلم في حاله بلد
زي مصر على استيراد القمح من الخارج معلوم
ان وسط الثور حوالي 50% من احتياجاتها من
القمح من
الخارج القمح سلعه اساسيه هو اكثر السلع
اساسيه لانه معناها ان تكون او لا تكون
مضبوط غلاء
الانسان فلما ا يكون انت خلينا نقول مثلا
انه سعر طن القمح في الخارج 200 دولار
اوكي لما يكون السعر 30 جنيه للدولار
فيبقى السعر في الداخل بكام ب 30 في 200
تمام مضبوط تمام لما
السعر يترفع ل 50 يبقى في الحاله تبقى 50
في ايه في 200 في 200 خلاص هذا الارتفاع
لن يترتب
عليه
انخفاض استهلاك مصر من القمح باعتبار
القمح سلعه ضروريه ولانها سلعه ضروريه ف
المرون السعريه للطلب تبقى ضعيفه ضعيفه
فلن تستفيد انما هيترتب على هذا ارتفاع
الثمن بالعمله الوطنيه وبالتالي ارتفاع
التكلفه بكل ما يترتب على ذلك واحد اثنين
نقطه منسيه جدا في هذا
الجدل انك انت لما يكون هيكل الانتاج عندك
بمعنى المنشات الصناعيه
والزراعيه تعتمد في نشاطها على مستلزمات
انتاج وارده من الخارج بنسبه كبيره يبقى
مع كل تراجع في سعر العمله الوطنيه تكلفه
مستلزمات الانتاج المستورده بترتفع
وبالتالي الميزه اللي ممكن تتحقق من ا
انخفاض سعر الصادرات وبالتالي تحفيز
الخارج على شراء كميات اكبر منها بتضيع
نتيجه لارتفاع التكلفه بسبب
دي خاصيه مصريه كبيره جدا اللي هي بنسميها
احنا ارتفاع المكون الاجنبي للانتاج
المحلي انا عاو استاذ حضرتك ان انا اقول
مثال مقابل لمصر عشان تبقى الصوره اوضح
وصحح لي يعني فرصه فوجد حضرتك انه مثلا
التعويم او خفض العمله في حاله الصين
مثالي جدا ليه كما افهم يعني ان هو عنده
قدره انتاجيه ضخمه وبالتالي يقدر انه اذا
انخفضت اذا كانت عملته منخفضه هتبقى عنده
انتاج كبير جدا مغري للمستثمر الخارجي او
الدول الخارجي ان تشتريه فهت الشري بكميات
كبيره وبالتالي هيديه نقد كبير وبالتالي
يبقى عنده حاله جيده الامر الثاني انه
هيكون عنده مرونه في حاله الواردات
الخارجيه لانه مش بيستورد كل شيء اساسي
عنده مبوط يعني مثلا مش مساله حياه او موت
انه يستورد القمح من بره في حاله البترول
جايز يعني و بالتالي لانه عنده مرونه اذا
وجد ان في سلع خارجيه غاليه جدا عليه ممكن
يستبدلها بمنتج محلي بمنتج اخر هل انا
فاهم صح كده صحيح هذا الوضع لا ينطبق على
معظم دول الاقتصادات نشاه يعني او
الاقتصادات الفقيره اه ومنها دول المنطقه
لان ما عندهاش جهاز انتاجي وبالتالي وحتى
الجهاز الانتاجي ماهواش ضخم جدا سانيا
بتستورد مش سلع رفاهيه سلع بالغه الحيويه
وما عندهاش قدره ان هي تستغنى عنها بالضبط
معنى مع دهش قدره دي بيترجم في انه اللي
انا قلته الكلام المتقع المرونه لا يج مر
السعريه لكن في بعداني لموضوع لابد الاشار
ليه الا وهو الكلام ده بالنسبه
لايه لما
يتداول يوم بعد يوم شهر بعد شهر سنه بعد
السنه ما في شيء اخر اللي هو الاصول ي
تتكلم على
مثلا منشات انتاجيه وحدات انتاجيه بنوك كل
الكلام ده مع التخفيض سعر العمله الوطنيه
بتصبح كل هذه الاصول منخفضه منخفضه امام
الاجنبي امام الاجنبي وبالتالي في نوع من
اعاده توزيع الثروه بين الداخل والخارج
متضمن في هذه العمليه ده صحيح ا
انه الجنيه نفترض دلوقتي انه الدولار ب 30
بقى الدولار نظريا يعني للتسهيل بقى ب 60
معناها انه الاجنبي يستطيع ان يشتري كل ما
هو مطروح للبيع تقريبا باقل من 50 بحوالي
مبو ده صحيح طيب انا هسال حضرتك السؤال
احنا هو يعني قد لا يخفى على كثيرين ان
عمليه التعويم لها ضرر واضح لانه حتى لو
لم يكن اقتصاديا فهو يعيش في هذا البلد
وفي غيره كلما انخفض الجنيه امام الدولار
ارتفعت السلع وتضرر تضررت الغالبيه يعني
انما هو السؤال ما هو البديل اللي حضرتك
بترح على الحكومه الحاليه اذا بقت يعني او
على الحكومه المقبله اذا تشكلت حكومه
مختلفه يعملوا ايه هذا هو الوضع الحالي
ماذا يفعلوا بديلا عن تعويم الجنيه تمام
هنا بوسع
المنظور قليلا
وننظر الموضوع بتاع التعويم في النهايه في
جوهره موضوع اعاده صياغه اساس العلاقه بين
الداخل
والخارج من خلال قوى السوق ده بتغير سعر
الاسعار وربما يكون اهم الاسعار وزي ما
سميته سره منظومه الاسعار في الاقتصاد
اللي هو سعر ليه الصرف ده بالنسبه للتعوير
انت بتسالني طب نعمل ايه اذا كان الوضع
كما ترى وتقول وانا بقول الاتي انا هغير
عيد صياغه العلاقه بين الداخل والخارج
ولكن ليس بالاعتماد على قوه السوق من خلال
سعر الصرف وانما من خلال
اليات تتيحها شروط وقواعد التجاره
العالميه لا مش التجاره العالميه عضويه
مصر في الجهه الحارسه على نظام التجاري
الدولي اللي هي منظمه التجاره العالميه ده
اللي انا بقول التجاره الع منظام التجاره
العالميه منظار التجاره العالميه منظام
التجاره العالميه لها دستور الدستور ده
بنسميه الاتفاقيه العامه للتعريفات
والتجاره اخر طبعه لهذه
الاتفاقيه صدرت في اواخر الثمانينات واعت
ودت في اوائل التسعينات في مراكش كويس كده
1994 تحديدا وفي
مراكش اجتمع المجتمع التجاري الدولي قراوا
هذا الدستور اللي هو بنود الاتفاقيه
العامه للتعريفات والتجاره بعد سجال استمر
حوالي اكثر من ع سنوات مفاوضات قصيه جدا
وانتهت بهذا الموضوع فده الدستور وانشات
منظمه التجاره العالميه باعتبارها الكيان
الذي سيسهر على تنفيذ هذا الدستور بيقول
ايه بقى وايه اللي ممكن يستفيدوا احنا
الموضوع بيقول ات ان الاقتصاد اقتصاد
البلد العضو العضو في منظمه التجاره
العربيه الذي يتعرض لصدمات خارجيه قاسيه
او
شديده تؤثر على مجمل الاوضاع والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه وربما السياسيه من حقه ان
يلجا الى ادوا
ل التحكم في تجارات الخارج بالذات تجاره
الواردات يعني تقليل الواردات
قد تصل الى حد حظر الواردات في حدها
الاقصى وقد تكون حظ الوردات لفتره معينه
وقد
تكون تقرير حصص معينه لما يستورد حد اقصى
خلال فتره
معينه او رفع الرسوم الجمركيه كمان
الحمايه مظبوط الحمايه اجراءات حمايه في
المطلق ولكن لها شرط مهم اللي هو ان يكون
ذلك بالتوافق مع اعضاء المنظمه الاخرين
ممن يعنيهم الامر انت عاييز خفض ساله او
او او تقلل المستورد لفتره او تعمل حصه
بتيجي منين من الهند يبقى ادخل في تفاهم
مع الهند لعمليه ودي عمليه مش مش ماهيش
سهله ولكن مش صعبه صعبه ممكن في و في دول
جربت الكلام ده ونفذت من حق الدوله طبقا
ل دستور منظمه التجاره العالميه انها في
ظروف معينه ظروف الشده خلينا
نسميها تفرض قيود من شانها ان تقلل من
قيمه فاتوره الوردات الى ان يجتاز
الاقتصاد مرحله الشده التي هو فيها سؤال
مع دكتور دي واحد واحد افضل
اثنين ا هو انت يعني ما يتم استيراده من
الخارج وما يتم تصديره الى الخارج في
نهايه مرتبط بما تنتجه وبما تستهلكه في
الحالتين صح فانت بحاجه الى اعاده النظر
فيما تنتجه وما تستهلكه
ا من خلال ادوات السياسه الماليه السياسه
النقديه
ا سياسه الاستثمار عايز اقول انه هنا
ترسانه الاسلحه الاقتصاديه المركونه انا
عايز اشغلها كويس كده بحيث انه ابتدي اعيد
تشكيل
ا نمط الانتاج ونمط الاستهلاك بما يؤدي في
نهايه المطاف الى تقليل واردات من الخ وزي
اظبط كده او التقشف زي ما صح كده صح كده
بس معال الدكتور سواء استخدمت مصر او
غيرها من الدول حقها في تقييد الواردات
بالاتفاق مع المنظمه او مع الدول ثنائيا
او انه الدوله تكشفت ده يكون خيارات جيده
برضو لو انا عندي جهاز انتاجي شغال لو انا
بعتمد على نسبه معتبره في السلع اللي انا
بصنعها او في السلعه الاساسيه اللي انا
بستهلك على الخارج ماذا تفيدني هذه
المقترحات يعني هتبقى الفايده فيها محدوده
لا ما هو ده مرتبط بتغير في في النظره
الكليه للاشياء
بمعنى انك انت بدل ما نزعتك انك بثور من
الخارج كل ما يمكن راده من الخارج لا تغير
هذه النظره انه لابد من تعزيز القدرات
الانتاجيه ودي امور يعني الناس بتتصور
انها محتاجه لسنوات ولا مش صحيح الكلام د
مثلا خد موضوع القمح على سبيل المثال اللي
حاصل الان حاليا انك
انت
بالنسبه للانتاج مصر المحلي من القمح
الفلاح اللي بينتج القمح معارض عليه سعر
الحكومه عارض عليه سعر ايوه 1600 جنيه
للطن للاردب متاسف كويس طيب سؤال بقى هل
ده سعر يحفز اه فهمتك لا هو لا يحفز ليه
لانه خلي بالك حاليا واحنا بنتكلم سعر طن
القمح عالميا حوالي 400 دولار كويس كده
والسعر المعروض من الحكومه على الفلاح
المصري لو حسبت حسبه اللي هي نسبه الاردب
ال الطن سبع ارادب لكل طن كويس كده فاضرب
الرقم ده في سبعه يديني السعر لطن بالجنيه
المصري اقاسم على سعر الصرف اللي هو 30
يطلعي 360 اهو 65 انت بتتكلم على 300
خلينا نقول 365 دولار ايوه بالمقارنه
بالسعر عالمي اللي انت بتستورد بيه خلي
بالك انت بتستورد من الخارج بهذا السعر ما
يقرب من 400 دولار للطن يعني مصر الحكومه
بتستورد ب 400 بس بتطلبه من الفلاح ب 365
مزبوط كده سؤال هل ده
يحفز الفلاح المصري على ذات انتاجه من
القمر بالتاكيد لا انا عندي سؤال لحضرتك
يعني هو بديهي ولكن اظن ان حضرتك في وضع
ممكن يدينا اجابه ما مشكله المسؤولين في
دوله زي مصر وفي دول اخرى مع قضيه الانتاج
يعني هل هي غائبه هل هي مثلا قوى ومراكز
ضغط الاستيراد خليني نستدعي يعني
ا سؤال بديع جدا وجزء منه يعني هو سؤال
متعدد الابعاد لكن انا جاوك مدخلين
مختلفين كويس ا
هناك
فيلسوف من اصول افريقيه
فرنسي جزائري الجنسيه اسمه فرانز فانون
بيتكلم على ايه بؤساء الارض ك ده عنوان
كتاب مشهور جدا ده مث اه ذا ريتد او ذا
ايرث اه ابس خلق الله اه طرح مفهوم لطيف
جدا بيقول لك انه في ظاهره لابد ان اتوقف
عندها اللي هي ظاهره ايه
بقى البشره السوداء والقناع الابيض ده
تلاقي فارقه وفي مثلا منطقه الكريبي لونه
مسود اه ولكن لابس قناع عضد بمعنى انه لا
يرى كل شيء الا من خلال ال الخواجات الغرب
ده موضوع يعني مثير جدا للاهتمام ويمكن قد
يبدو بعيد عن الاقتصاد لكن هو في صلب اصاد
هو الاساس اللي تبنى عليه التصورات
والتصرفات الشيء الثاني برض متصل بهذا
الموضوع بين هجاج بشكل مباشر من خلال
تجربتي انا كوزير ممارس بس الاول النقطه
الاولانيه نوضحها للناس تقصد انه الناس
اللي موجودين هنا سياسيين واقتصاديين
بيفكروا بمنطق ايه يعني للتوضيح ايه
المنطق بتاعه بطق بمنطق الاخر اه او
المتسلط او المسيطر
ها سميها ما شات انما في النهايه لو قلنا
ابيض هو في في المشهد الحالي هو الابيض هو
الغرب يعني مضبوط هو الغرب ا هناك مقوله
اخرى بتتكلم هذا النوع من البشر ومنه
مسؤولين بالمناسبه دون ان اقدح في احد
بالضروره يتكلم على الكومبرادور اه تعبير
يمكن اتكلمنا عليه قبل كده و تعبير
برتغالي اصلا واستدعي في هذا السياق سياق
العلاقه بين الداخل والخارج للاشاره الى
ا
مواطنون بعضهم مسؤولون
همهم شغل الشغل هو ترويج بضاعه
الاجانب بين بني جلدتهم طيب سؤالك بقى ده
طبعا بهذا المفهوم مساله نفسيه صح اه لكن
الموضوع اخطر من ذلك في بنيه العلاقه بين
الداخل والخارج بتجد ان هناك قوى ضغط
ومجموعات مصالح تضغط لابقاء الاوضاع في
الخارج طب لاغاء بقاء الاوضاع على ما هي
عليه في في البلد اللي بنتكلم عنه وهناك
قوى ا من الداخل من الداخل متحالفه معها
ناخد مثال يكون وضح لنا القصه يا دكتور
مثال وضح مثلا خد القمح في حاله مصر ما
حدش يقدر يجاد الموضوع هو يعني سلعه السل
موضوع الموضوعات باعتبار انه انت بتعتمد
على كل رغيف منتج في مصر نصه منشاه الخارج
عظيم ومع ذلك الحكومه بتدي للفلاح المصري
360 ولا 65 دولار في حينها بتشتري من
الفلاح الفرنسي او الامريكي 400 دولار
تمام طيب هنا ايه اللي بيحصل في حاله
القمح
انه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفرنسا
وكل الدول التي تبيع قمح بتنظر الى مصر
نظره خاصه جدا انه اكبر مستهلك طب يعمل
ايه يبتدي يشوف منابع اتخاذ القرار
بالنسبه لشراء القمح الخ
ويبتدي يعني يتعامل معها عند هذا المستوى
بتاخد وزير التموين لما انا كنت وزير
تموين وتجربه سجلتها في الكتاب وسجلتها
عندنا وسجلتها وسجلتها هنا ادي دي حاجه
الحاجه الثانيه في ب بس للتوضيح للي ما
كانش متابعنا انه بيجي مسؤولين من فرنسا
امريكا لمقابله وزير التموين زي الدكتور
جوده ما كان في فتره من الفترات في محاوله
للضغط عليه للابقاء على وضع مصر كاكبر
مستور مط بالخلفيه احنا كنا بنخلط الذره
بالقمح عشان انتاج الرغيف وبالتالي بنقلل
استيرادنا من الخارج ده كان موضوع مزعج
جدا رغم ان النسبه كانت في وقتها 10% يعني
ك مفكر زده 15% زائد اللوبي انجاز التعبير
بتاع التجار مستوردين في الداخل ا دي دي
حاجتين الحاجتين الثانيه مرتبط بيه بقى
ادوات الهيمنه في الخارج لما تيجي تشوف
مين المتحكم في تجاره الحبوب على المستوى
العالمي هي شركات دوليه النشاط كبرى ربما
اها شركه من الشركات الامريكيه المشهور
جدا وبالمناسبه هي شركه عائليه في النهايه
كارجل كارجل اه اي اوكي فده الموضوع
وبالتالي انت هنا بقى بب كيف تتعامل مع
هذا ده يعني اعتقد انه خارج عن نط
الاقتصاد بالمعنى البحت عاوز اراده سياسيه
يعني مضبوط عاوز اراده
سياسيه والله يا معالي الدكتور ده يعني
ليه جانبين يعني
يعطينا هو في كل الاحوال جيد عشان نفهمه
يعطينا امل كمان يعطينا امل انه انه
المساله ماهش معقده اقتصاديا جدا لا ولكن
المساله تتوقف على ايمان صناع القرار بانه
هذا يمكن ان يتحقق اه عايز بس قبل ما نترك
هذه النقطه السيده اوضح مسال تين اضافيتين
نقطه منسيه تقريبا في كل هذا الجدل اللي
هي نقطه نظام الصرف نظام
الصرف اللي هو الدول بتحدد سعر صرف عملتها
على اساس في دول تقوللك والله انا يعني
تقريبا مقدرات كلها مرتبطه بالدولار فانا
هربط عملتي بالدولار خد مثال دول الخليج
ميهش اه صحيح واذلك تلاحظ كل ما البنك
الفيدرالي يرفع سعر الفائده يرفع هم سعر
الفائده كمان سعر صرف عملتهم مع الدولار
تقريبا لا يتحرك لانه معظم دخلهم بهذه
السلعه لانه بيبيع نفط وغاز خلاص اللي هي
بتباع بالدولار بالضبط كده اوكي لكن في
دول وعلى فكره احنا كده احنا رابطين سعر
الجنيه بالدولار هي دي النقطه وده الخطا
الكبير انما عايز اقول في بدائل تانيه ايه
انك بدل ما تربط بعمله واحده تربط بله
عملات ليه سله عملات لانه لما بتربط عمله
واحده واحده لما بيحصل العمله دي سعرها
يزيد او يقل بيعمل عندك ارباك مباشر وشديد
و وحال انما بتربط بسله عملات فال الارجح
انه بالنسبه لهذه اعضاء هذه السله العملات
المكونه لها بعضها يرتفع في سعره وبعضها
ينخفض سعره بحيث انه في النهايه الحركه
تكون اقل حده من الحركه في حاله الربط
بايه بسعر عمله واحده مفهوم يا مع الدكتور
يعني احنا مثلا اكبر شرك تجاري لنا هو
الاتحاد الاوروبي فاذا كانت هناك سله من
العملات ومنها مثلا اليورو له وزن كبير او
اليوان الصيني هيبقى الوضع الطف شويه مبوط
بس انا عندي سؤال برض ما هو احنا الجنيه
منخفض قدام كل هذه العملات نتيجه انه احنا
لا نصدر لها كثيرا يعني لا انا بتكلمك
دلوقتي مش على اجراء واحد اللي
هو اللعب بالسعر انجاز التعبير سعر العمله
على ام تحسن الاوضاع فالاوضاع تزداد سوءا
لا انا بتكلم على ترسانه من الادوات
تستخدم والاجراءات اضافه الى تغيير
المنظور مساله مهمه جدا جدا شوف التصور
يمكن انا قلت الكلام ده في اكثر من لقاء
التصور حاكم طبعا طبعا مش كده ولا ايه
طبعا تصور حاكم جدا فلما تتصور ان انت
مفعول به وتابع ومسلوب الاراده تجاه
الخارج خلاص انت خسرت المباراه قبل ان
تبدا دي مساله مهمه لكن معلش عشان بس اكمل
النقطه دي اللي هو بقى بالاضافه الى اللي
انا اقترحته انك تستخدم حقوقك في منظمه
التجاره العالميه وتعيد النظر في سلم
الاولويات عندك بحيث انه المجالات الانفاق
مثلا مشروعات
الاستثمار التي لها مكون اجنبي عالي جدا
وعندنا امثله كثيره في الحاله المصريه
تعيد النظر فيها بما لا يضر
بالحركه بتاعه الاقتصاد في المدى المباشر
والمدى المتواصل يعني يعني تعيد النظر في
مشروعات توقفها تؤجلها لانها تستهلك كميه
كبيره من النقد الاجنبي بالضبط وهي عامله
ازمه كبيره يعني بالضبط كده بالضبط كده
فده وطبعا هنا انا قلت اكتر من مره وضعنا
حاليا يستدعي ان انا اعلن اقتصاد
حرب و يمكن الكلمه صدمتك يعني ايه اقصاد ح
حرب برض دي مساله مهمه جده مهمه معناه
اقتصاد حرب
معناه
المجتمع يواجه تحديا
وجوديا ازاء الغير وبالتالي ينبغي ان يحكم
هذا كل القرارات والتصرفات في الداخل بما
يعزز فرص المجتمع في الانتصار امام هذا
التحدي الوجودي خطبه عصما انا عارف ل لا
يعني امثله توضح لنا العمليه انما عايز ا
يعني انا عندي الحكومه اللي جايه دي اللي
ه تتشكل فيها مصر هي خ الم خد موضوع
الاسعار انت بتتعامل مع الاسعار هنا يعني
مطبطب على التجار باماره ايه فاهم انما
لما تقول اوكي يا جماعه من دلوقتي احنا
هنطبق ادوات اقتصاد الحرب معناه وانا قلت
الكلام ده وقت ما كنت وزير اللي تاجر في
البوتاجاز في السوق السودا
هنم ليه لان انت في
معركه وهي معركه بكل المقاييس والمعركه
عشان
اوضح انت في وضع له ضحايا بالملايين يا
سيد طبعا مش كده ولا ايه ايوه لازم
المساله تفهم بهذا الايه بهذا الشكل
وبالتالي يعني التصور العام علاقتك
بالخارج موضوع الجل الملون والقناع الابيض
او الكومبرادور ده لازم تشوف لك حل فيها
كل دي مسائل يعني
خارج الرطانه الاقتصاديه ربما ولكنها اساس
لكل ا انجاز يمكن ان يحدث وبالتالي انا
بقول يا جماعه لو
سمحتم لابد ن حلحل الامور في هذا المجال
ولا نجري وراء سراب سراب التعويم انا عندي
لانه خراب انا عندي سؤال اخير لحضرتك
واستاذن لو اوجزت يعني بحيث انه تبقى
الصوره اوضح لمن يسمعنا من صناع
القرار او للناس يعني انت حضرتك قلت كلمه
يعني اوجزت فيها ما تريده من افكار اقتصاد
في عباره كاتشي على الدوله ان تتبنى
اقتصاد الحرب في حكومه جايه اذا كانت
الحكومه القائمه او جايه ولكن المفروض ان
في حكومه مقبله اذا ارادت ان تتبنى فكرتك
وتعلن اغتصاد حرب ممكن تعمل اجراءات
دراماتيك زي ايه اوكي انا
اقوللك اول
شيء في في مجال التعامل مع الخارج لا يمكن
يستمر كل شيء يعني كما هو ك اه ولابد ان
تحدث ان قطاعات جذريه مش مجرد تعديلات
حديه هنا وهناك ي زي مثلا انك انت تاخد
فاتوره الوردات تدرس التفاصيل وتحط
اولويات خلي بال عشان اقول الفرق بين ده
وبين ماتابعته الحكومه مره ج فاكر انت في
2022 لما حصل هروب
من رؤوس اموال الاجنبيه كذا و2 مليار ايه
كان قال لك اوكي خلينا نعمل لقتي ان اللي
بيستورد طبقا ل اسلوب ما يسمى مستندات
الدفع ها هنعمل بالاعتمادات المستنديه
مستندات الفع معناها ايه انت بتستورد من
مصدر اجنبي بتقدم للسلطات الجمارك عندنا
ما يفيد انك انت سددت قيمه هذه البضاعه
بطريقتك خلاص ده النظام اللي كان معمول به
لغايه وادى الى انفجار في قيمه وانواع
الواردات لما حصل ضغط بسبب نزوح رؤوس
الاموال تقول لا نغير الكلام ده نوقف
العمل بمستندات التحصيل
ونعمل القاعده اللي هي المفروض واجبه
وطبيعيه اللي هي ا الاعتمادات المستن يعني
ايه اعتمادات المستن ان انا اروح البنك
اقول له انا ثوره كذا من المصدر الفلاني
وطبقا للتعامل بينا قيمه البضاعه المستوره
قد كده ولو سمحت ادي المقابل بالجنيه
المصري نحوله عليه عظيم فنقله من مستندات
التحصيل
اللي كان ساري بيه لغايه 22 كان المستورد
بيدبر العمله الاجنبيه بنفسه فكان في سوق
سودا يعني ا وفي انفجار في قيمه وحجم
الوردات تمام الى الى الاعتمادات المستهد
وهو
الاسلوب اللي كان يجب ان يتم الالتزام بيه
خلاص ولكن كل ده في حدود ايه انك انت برض
سايب المجال مفتوح اللي يقدر يدبر ف طلع
انه مثلا شركات ادويه ما قدرتش تدبر بتاع
فصوصه تاثر انتاج الاجواء في مجال حيوي
جدا في الداخل يعني بقول التحرك بتشير الى
انه كمان ده الخطوه دي هتتطلب ان يكون في
اولويات فيما تستورده مش مش كل من يرغب في
استيراد شيء يستورده مبوط ده واحد واحد
اثنين انا عندي طاقات انتاجيه عاطله
بالفعل هناك حاجه اسمها مصانع مغلقه من
ايام ثوره 2011 ولم نسع عن كم تصريح انما
الموضوع لم يعد يتداول على الاطلاق ليس
معنى ذلك ان هذه المصانع عملت عادت للعمل
لا لم تعد للعمل
وبالتالي انت لازم تخد ايه ايه المشكله
بتاعته هل مشكله مع البنك تعالج هذه المكل
هل مشكله مع مثلا جهات حكوميه معينه تعالج
هذا بحيث انه انت ممكن تدفع بعدد معتبر من
المصانع للعمل مره تانيه العمل مره ثانيه
ده يشغل فرص عمل يخلق حركيه في السوق يزود
قدرتك الانتاجيه في مواجه الا الخارج عظيم
نمره لاثه لازم تتبع ادوات سوق المعتبره
في
الايه الحفز ها والحجب بمعنى انه احنا
اتكلمنا عن موضوع القمح لازم في عمليه
التسعير بالنسبه لمحاصيل زراعيه مهمه تعمل
ايه الكلام دوت انك تعطي السعر جيد للسلعه
اللي انت ترغب في انتع
صناعات او زرا او سياحه او غيره او خدمات
يعني بالضبط كده اه فهنا
اما تعمل اولويات الوردات وتطبق بصرامه
وبمنطق اقتصادي خلي بالك يعني ك بقول
اقتصاد حربي يعني بالعصب والسكين لا لابد
ان يعني يوجهها منطق اقتصادي يميز بين
الضروري والاقل الاهم والاقل ايه اهميه
حتى لا يحدث ارتباك في الساحه الايه في
الساحه الاقتصاديه يلي ذلك بقى انك ل انت
جزء من اقتصاد الحرب انه في الانفاق
الجاري في الموازنه العامه
للدوله هذا الانفاق لابد ان يعاد النظريه
في اتجاه تخفيضه بنسبه معتبره وانا قلت
اكثر من مره انت ممكن جدا في الحاله
المصريه وانا بتكلم من واقع تجربه كوزير
سابق انك انت تخفض الانفاق الجاري في
الموازنه العامه للدوله بنسبه الخمس 20%
بارتياح شديد جدا يعني تفاصيل كتيره في 20
في يمكن الاستغناء عن د معانه مبو اه يعني
انت بتتكلم على واحد من كل خمسه جنيه ايه
القضيه يعني ها بس المهم تدرس وتيه وتاخد
قرار وتطبق القرار بايه بحسم ده طبعا
هيسمع في الناحيه الثانيه بتاع نادي
الاجنبي الجزء من الفاق الجاري ده بيترجم
على طول لما مطبوعات الحكومه خد بناها ده
بند من البنو لا ق لما مطبوعات الحكومه
ايه يا فندم مطبوعات الحكومه المكون
الاجنبي فيها عالي جدا لان انت بلد مستورد
للورق من الخارج بالكامل اهه على سبيل
المثال ها او حتى الاقلام اللي بيتكتب بيه
او يعني اشياء من هذا تصحك ان التقشف
هينتج عنه بالضرير تقليل للواردات
الخارجيه اه مبوط مبوط بديهي بالاضافه الى
الاولويات اللي لابد ان تعيد النظر فيها
فيما يتعلق بما يسمى المشروعات القوميه
وخلينا نسميها مشروعات الاستثمار ا في
المجمل ده ده ده مقتضى اقتصاد الحرب ل
مقتضى الفكره ايه بقى في اقتصاد الحرب
هعبر عنها بتاع كبير يعني كل الناس مب
اقول لك اللي يعوز البيت يحرم على الا على
الجامع
اه وبالتالي يعني جوهر فكره حرك في اقتصاد
الحرب هي انه الدوله تكون تتدخل بشكل اكثر
مما تفعل الان ولكن هذا التدخل يكون هدفه
ضبط الاوضاع واحد اهم ادوات التدخل او
اهدافه لازم يكون في تقشف والحكومه تبدا
بنفسها وتبدا بنفسها من خلال تقشف في
الموازنه العامه وتبدا بنفسها فيما يتعلق
بال المشروعات اللي هي بتتبن اذا كان فيها
مكون دولاري خصوصا او اذا كان ليست
المشروعات ديت عاجله جدا ان يتم تاجيلها
ورقابه الى حد كبير يعني على السوق زي ما
انا فاهم من حضرتك لا رقابه صارمه يعني
موضوع اصل خلي بالك لما قلت اقتصاد حرب
التعبير ما جاش من فراغ انا قلته لسببين
السبب الاول انك انت ك اقتصاد بتتعرض
لصدمه شديده جدا جايه من الخارج لاسباب
كتيره لا داعي للخوض فيها لكن الامر
الثاني انت عندك خطر محدق على الحدود على
كل الحدود ايوه على كل الحدود مش كده ولا
ايه اه يعني حتى الناس ما بتاخدش بالها ان
اليمن من حدودنا يعني لا طبعا حدودك في
المجال الحيوي فكره المكلم على اليمن
بنتكلم على السودان بنتكلم على ليبيا
بنتكلم طبعا في فلسطين المحتله وبنتكلم
على الوضع العالمي ملته بالضبط كده لا
وبالتالي دي القراءه الاستراتيجيه اثيوبيا
مش قراءه لا مؤاخذه القراءه البورصجيه
يعني لو الاسعار طلعت نزلت كل الكلام ده
ده
ده يعني في الهامش بالمقارنه بلوب
الموضوع والله ده يعني حضرتك فاجئتني
بفكره اقتصاد الحرب التي يجب ان تتبناها
الدوله او الحكومه المقبله في مصر واضح ان
حكومات اخرى يجب ان تتبناها استاذنك ان
انا استانف معاك الحديث عن هذه الفكره في
حلقات
اخرى ونستغل الفرصه ان الناس هتطرح اسئله
ف استاذن حضرتك ان الحلقه المقبله اللي
قلناه على سعر الصرف والمرت ده تكون ان
شاء الله مع الاسئله وال لمزيد من انا
بعتذر لناس حاولت ابسطه قد انما اسئلتهم
طبعا هتبقى منيره جدا نا في شكرا جزيلا
معال الدكتور شكرا جزيل